こんにちははっちゃんですはいというわけでこの家に引っ越してきてだいたいも1週間
2週間ぐらい経つんですけど
あのん
もうこれですよね聞こえたかなあの前まで住んでた僕のいいか違う場所には住んでるん
ですけどこの家に引っ越してすげー困ったことがありまして
隣の人が街でうるさいですよ
今もうるさかった
ほらメッツるだろめっちゃなよ誰だ
おっとっとすよね喧嘩すると売れないんです菌活売ってるつもりはないんですけど本当
にうるさくてもうほんともう殺せる増しているお金ぐらいの気持ちなんですけど
運営の方が折れちゃう人ちょっと行ってみますほんと困ったものですよ
ちなみにまとも竹が取りに来ております新居です
ってこっちも冬用に猫達の部屋にそういったんだ部屋がいい
いやや焙煎までしどんどん言ってましたもうなぜでこっちのカメラ見た分
骨でにそっちもはいというわけで隊は家の形的にこっちから聞こえるよねまずうるさい
ですよ
何ですかね
と言うとねべ戦でも4わたるんでしょてびびったしょこのボールの新しいが思っており
しっかり
本当に何かちゃんと家になってジャンスカ2曲を終えたんだよねこちら潰された感じで
を得られますただ本当こっち側なんだよね俺触ったんです
[音楽]
こっちの伝えてみる
あ
なぜ叩いていい
でも向こうがうるさいからこれが少ないと思うんですよ
たたき化してみませんだ
えっ
ん
バップ
おっん
規約のれから低めの人はされませんやばくないでもこれじゃぶぁーしてうるさいんです
よなんか動画とっている時もうるさくて結構迷惑してて
ってこと俺もうるさいってことかなんんーっほらもうやばいよこいつや俺は何だろう
けど
あ
ん
あれ違いますけどねあっはぁ
[音楽]
パロディだねーよあ
絶対ようかけたもこれ
何人かいる23によりますねさんに異例
ちょっとベランダから見てみたい
つだよね多分
すみません
寄せ隣の人ですか
セミナーのちょっと
なんかもの音がひどいんですけど
[音楽]
ブータンでクラウドするんです
あそれでこっちもうるさいが悪いと思うんですけど夜中とかちょっとだけ政府がに従っ
ていいですか
中部叩くのでやめてもらっていいですか
虫やばくねこれでも削りさせ気でしょ俺も大概だと思うけど
はるかに俺のレベルを超えている
鳥ついてこれるかないかいちょっと家が出てくればとなり
いやーこれは強いでしょ例えばを通じてくる
いたいやもう馴染めますよリスってくるさすがに絶対こういう時に叩いてますもあって
ちょっとまず有り得なすぎますね
絶対はずされているもとなりやれ
1回本気で注意していきます申します
いません
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
みてください
えっ
ああああああ
はいそれは安いですよ早速ようですよね
少してね